Thủ cướng chính phủ phạm mình chính vừa có công diện số 1 tảm ba ngày 12 tháng 11 chỉ đạo các bộ ngành
để phương tập trung khắp phục ngành hợp và bạo số 1 lời và mưa lũ.
Công diện gửi, chủ tịch ui bán nhân dân các tình thành phố,
khoảng ninh, lặng sân, thải phòng, hương yên, ninh bình, thành hóa, nguyện an,
hà tính, khoảng chi, khế, đảnh, phú thuật, quân quan, sân la, lào cai, cao bằng,
thái nguyên, bắt ninh, hà nội, bian biên, lai châu, bộ trưởng,
thủ trưởng cơ quan ngàng bộ, cơ quan thuật chính phủ, văn phòng văn chỉ đạo phòng thu dân sự quốc gia.
Trong công diện, thủ tưởng yêu cơ các tình thành phố nếu trên, hình chương ra soát,
lánh giá, thống cây thải sau báo số 1 lời và mưa lũ, nhất là về nhà ở của nhân dân.
Cơ sở sổng, y tế, hạ tần thiết yếu, cơ sở sản soát, kinh suán, dịch vụ,
hửi bộ tài chính, bộ nông nhập và môi trưởng, văn phòng chính phủ, chậm nhất trước mười dờ ngày 18 tháng người.
Ngoài ra, các địa phương vi động tối ra lực lượng khổ chợ nhân dân xây dựng nhà mới,
sở chớ nhà cơ bị tóc mái, hư hồng khổ chợ chua ở tạm đối với các khổ dân bị mất nhà cơ
giò bà số 1 lời theo quy đình, không đẹn người dân không có chua ở.
Chỉnh hai các chính xác khổ chợ trong khả năng có thể, đối với các gia đình có người chết,
mất tích gia đình có nhà bị sập đồ, chôi hồng theo đúng quy đình,
hoàn thành chậm nhất trong ngày 1 năm tháng người.
Thủ tưởng cốc yêu cầu xử chữa ngày các trường hồng, cơ sở giáo dục,
tí tế bị tóc mái hư hồng so báo người lũ, hoàn thành chức ngày 1 năm tháng người.
Tại đối không để học sinh, thiếu trường, thiếu lấp, thiếu xách và lồ dùng học tập, người dân,
thiếu nơi khám chứa bạnh khi ủng đau. Thủ tưởng yêu cầu vụ trường vô tại chính,
khẩn trường tồng hợp, để sốt hối trở ngày kinh phí khá khục hẩn cấp hợp vào bảo số người,
và người lũ cho các nghiệp vâng báo cáo tủ tưởng chính phụ, sau ngày 1 2 tháng người.